what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm gonna
talk about my weight loss journey uh
so when i graduated high school i was a
hundred and
eighty pounds and throughout college
there was times where i like lost weight
and i gained rate but i basically was
between
170 at my lowest and maybe like 190 at
my highest and this sounds like a lot
but i'm six foot so if i do
um like i've done a bmi calculator i'm
very strong so i dead lift like 200
pounds or 300 pounds
squat to 60. i want to say i did 265 by
five sets the other day so i don't know
what that would be one rep but
it doesn't really matter
so
fluctuated 170 to 190. when i first
graduated college and i worked in sales
for two years i actually gained a lot of
weight like
pretty fast
like really fast
so i gained i went from 190 to like 205
and that was the heaviest i've ever been
oh my god and when i saw that it broke
200 i was devastated so i ran a marathon
um
to lose the weight um some people would
just eat better no i decided i'm running
a marathon
and it worked um i got down to
1
85 190
and
the thinnest so in the past year the
thinnest i've been is like 179 the
heaviest i've been is 190. and i've
really stuck like in the 1
70 to 190 more like 180 to 190 range for
a couple years
but i'm delusional
i think because most people if they just
keep doing the same thing over and over
again and like having the same results
they'd like stop trying or maybe you
know give up
but
i'm convinced that at some point one of
the diets one of the workouts that i try
something that i try is going to work
i don't know what because i really want
to get to 1
170. it's not that much weight that i
have to lose but i just cannot seem to
get past
180 really i haven't in a couple years
i'm 185 now so we'll see what happens
but
yeah i think i think i'm delusional to
be honest because i am convinced that
i'm the exception i'm convinced that one
day i will figure out foods that i like
that are healthy i will figure out
habits that i can consistently keep
and
i think it's good that i'm delusional
because um most of my friends
that
quit or kind of stop tracking their food
and like being crazy like me like trying
a million different diets trying a
million different things
uh they're bigger than me now
and i've just stayed the same weight for
the most part
so
that's just my two cents of the day
i think i'm close to figuring it out
because
i have this new idea this new thing i'm
trying and it's not really a diet so to
speak i decided to think about like
foods that are healthy that i actually
genuinely enjoy
i don't like salads i've never liked
salads so i'm not gonna try to make
myself like salads
although i have before
and then i quit that so
um
and so i came up with sushi so like
pokey bowls i've been making
um chicken and hot sauce and like rice
or like sometimes potatoes just whatever
carb that's gluten free i've tried to
stay gluten free um banana peanut butter
smoothies strawberry smoothie just like
smoothies in general i really like
um
what else it's like pretty much those
three things
um
oh and steak steak is the fourth thing i
really like and i've been trying to eat
the same things over and over again
because in my head
like it's easier to track what i eat in
a day if it's just the same thing again
and again
and i'm a little scared that i'm gonna
get sick of this these foods and then be
stuck at square one that might happen
but so far my skin is the biggest thing
that has cleared so you'll see this is
clear i have a little bit of acne here
but if you look
at my videos from a couple months ago my
acne was out of control and now
i'm like almost clear i'm down
seven pounds or six pounds maybe from
when i started i think i was like 191
when i got to england so
i don't know i'll keep you guys posted
but i'm determined one of these days i
will be the exception to the rule and i
will figure this out and i will get to
my dream weight
and you guys will be there with me the
whole time